[Music]
[Applause]
whoa all themself guy remember because
it won't fucking chef I mean I got every
sense overview the first Ghost Rider
movie all you guys have been saying is
from you feels right into you repeat
goes right into you with so much within
the first one will find you barking dogs
of entitlement here's the goddamn DVD
here's the goddamn remote
let's goddamn watch it my god a British
present fellow critic my shame from
shameful sequels i back out the glasses
Carl one in 1984 my chin enjoyed our
simple childhood enough enough of that
critic I found a way to record myself
onto every ghost rider to DVD in the
world really yeah it was actually quite
easy well I've done it because no
reviewer not even the nostalgia critic
will be reviewed about ten films I
reviewed but we'll just ignore that all
to go because I can let it go like that
you have to sit through this flames gull
of dog shit alone wait how do you know
everything I'm going to say because this
movie is actually so repetitive and
predictable it's actually given me the
ability to predict everything in the
world which is mediocre wait a minute
thank you my mediocre yeah but you get
abused oh yeah
what do you think you can predict
everything that's mediocre predicted my
fingers gonna have to hold up one I
guess one again to again an unopened
Gameboy a roll of Hello Kitty duct tape
and an Optimus Prime doll going down
trust me critic you need help on this
one
[Music]
whereas the first film was underwhelming
of silly
this one is painful and obnoxious for
every problem they try to fix from the
last movie to Lord just as ridiculous
takers place it's ludicrous it makes no
sense and it's a pain in the ass to sit
through nobody giving you Yuri reviewing
prick should review it on their own
you know the only or issue I have is
that you're a Brit wanting to do a
crossover that might anger another Brit
wanting to do a crossover what hombre
don't worry about him he's gonna be at
commission for a while bro brother
so critic are you ready once again to
see the hideous length Nicolas Cage's
willing to go to for a paycheck
given that the column every Nicolas Cage
movie this is Ghost Rider spirit of
vengeance and I gave it already was I
going to got to be a new record
that fucking fast beats editing do you
really think your audience is so abd
that even the film logo is too slow for
than the watch watch to speed up the
whole fucking movie like I was going to
writer bye thank you Tom with rooms
better yeah they probably should dumber
but no belly again our drawn-out movies
starting in the leftover capital from
blood rain where a biker played by ether
is Elva rides it I found the boy come on
God is hundl from Thor now with nod it's
just the same actor know what the Marvel
movies must be connected he came through
the Rainbow Bridge to have Ghost Rider
join The Avengers this created that time
paradox where the Human Torch became
Captain America Bruce Banner would get
plastic surgery twice at Howard the Duck
would exist in the universe or he can
actually be funny what doesn't make
sense about that why family was in print
the diary to always fucking up the model
Kevin we see the rider name a row enter
a monastery full of what I'm now
considering the cinematic kiss of death
cyber monks because they went over so
well into Dennis
in movies clearly they proven to pass
the test of time a few days the winter
solstice will be tastin weather bureau
the prophecy the ministry is less oddly
enough by report from Buffy but bankers
break in and try to tear the place apart
[Music]
so it was this whole scene shot by a
bald head dull yeah the camera person
must have gotten off a tilt-a-whirl
before shooting this seat Oh where's our
camera were they most pathetic shut up
so was it worth adding that extra zero
in your checkbook to get anthony head
for that role to its credit he did look
eager not to be shot as a mother and her
boy asked a p-- with the bad guys
chasing them but luckily mauro has a
bullshit way to get rid of them thank
god this part slowed down so i can shoot
the car easier
we get our opening credits as Kage
narrates the bank story figuring you
probably fell asleep during the first
one and don't remember it I'm the guy
who made the deal with the devil I know
what you're thinking doesn't this kid
watch movies does this ever work out
home let's just say good judgment was
not exactly my forte I mean have you
seen my IMDB page it's a train wreck
we then see Kage meet up with Moreau who
seems to be alive and uninjured
how the bloody shit is that possible
he's not to be intervention of God okay
the true saving him is dumb enough but
why the hell did they play the French
national anthem maybe it was a French
tree Oh Bonjour that man I take it you
were doing detour blood Oh Laura wants
him to find the boy who escaped earlier
and protect him but cage has
reservations going after a child since
the last time he tried to do that we are
prepared to give to you
the one thing you want most of this
world we must avoid
and you lift your cars bring us away
with that oh I know you're gonna say
that minds think alike pedal that what's
it from so Kate agrees to the deal of
the boy's mother named Nadia tried to
schmooze over horny Mick curvier and
then issue a look at me yes a young Roma
gypsy I have a lot of money yeah hi
mommy I am this has been another episode
of cock-blocker
join us next time with a woman can't
stop talking about her genital warts
yeah well at least they're not enforcing
the stereotype that all gypsies at these
[Music]
hell oh this is just don't pass that
hit-and-run editing that one gettin run
editing where the director is so afraid
to lose your attention even for a second
that you'll speed up and slow down the
film under the pretense that it's
somehow artsy oh my god is everywhere
even in scenes where nothing's going on
especially in scenes where nothing's
going on it's like the editor think that
if some sort of rock star in the fast
forward bun is is amazing instrument
behold I am cut storm and I will rock
you with my extreme edit
look at that how'd I do that is because
I'm amazing now we're going to this shot
or maybe we're boy delish Sonic
maybe we're in three different shots at
one which was wish wish the whisper push
how am i doing all of this you will
never know is the magic of cuts dope
tune in next time as I improve The Great
Gatsby and submit - Lauren it's not an
annoying ass hat stoar but the bad guys
catch up with them and hold them at
gunpoint monkeys arrived in time as the
writer to put a stop to
[Music]
[Applause]
did ghosts try to get into the ghost
hatch before setting out on this mission
or the wind is like The Music Man I
think I had is made out of reefer
hey buddy I can do this really weird
thing to on does Ryder
[Music]
hmmm ghostwriter seems a little slower
and easily distracted this time around
if he trying to remember what he does I
say I'm supposed to do something
oh yeah scary a really good wad of her
contract for a left behind - alright I'm
scary again really bad you're
intimidating badass line for a tougher
thing said of the x-men cartoon of
course not
Keith wakes up in the hospital later
because though easily surviving jumping
off buildings getting hit by trucks and
being blown up several times later that
little explosion apparently needed
medical attention do you in he finds the
mother and they agree to partner up to
find the boy the boys apparently been
kidnapped by henchmen of the devil
planked this time by ciarán hinds
[Music]
carrying it I just love how that's the
devil's ringtone I mean the fucking
devil the ruler of all darkness the
destroyer of everything good his goddamn
ringtone is
that well chew truth have fuckin
spongebob squarepants white rat caring
it well it does kind of make sense soon
as this whole scene is shot like
somebody slide screen we have an
agreement Kerrigan you told me you get a
get weird things bad things think of the
giant as a sort of computer feel from
watching over backwards episode of 24
what's not to understand I want or just
an abusive a mistake take a boy seeing
how it goes writer can find anybody but
double speak some words into the boy's
ear that someone something like a
firewall no really that's actually
having clips I just uploaded a little
program a firewall event on the
motorcycle won't be able to sense him
now of course he still may be able to
find you so I suggest you keep going so
what was the point of the firewall King
ding dong ding dang dong what was that I
don't know I just try to what I have no
answers so one looking for the boy cage
finds out that the mother is again to
quote how the film puts it you're the
devil baby mama does that explain why
this whole scene is shot with the zoom
beans even though there is nothing going
on trying to kill you and blew me up you
were like boyfriend/girlfriend
is it symbolic entertaining those who
have the attention and of babies putting
movement it's okay to be pretty picture
kids also go to the detail but why the
devil may want to take human form
why does the devil walk on earth and
human form anyway
I have no idea passes on from body to
body down through history waiting for
the perfect fit oh come on movie of all
the funny people you could have put in
there that's the one you went with maybe
it was to help the devil baby mama line
seemed more credible so he finds them or
makes them using his greatest power the
power of ripping opping White Album
Garth the deal oh because you ripped off
a Pink Floyd album cover it's a touch
distracting it's kind of like having
your deal picture look like this it
might ring a few bells the mother finds
the one who might know where the boy is
being taken and get ready people this is
Nicholas Cage and is absolute kg Asst
Gryffindor yeah I'm sorry I was doing my
impression of Bobcat Goldthwait getting
castrated again please no one here it
won't be anything that you understand
there's nothing worth now I'm invisible
compared to your actor quality can't
explore where were gods prevent the
putting together god damn army after
getting the location cage rides off into
the night but small too important
mugging into the camera
[Music]
okay if this theme doesn't convince
people that cave literally want to take
these surgical procedures to become a
cartoon character I don't think anything
will no kidding every single one of
those faces could at their own cartoon
show right let's see here uh it's
pumpkin shit log the most adorable
jack-o'-lantern to ever nibble your dog
- too crazy a cereal mascot who gets
jiske if he doesn't get his sugar grams
seat Andy the clown teaching how to make
upside-down progress with construction
paper x2 speed he's not on anything he's
just quirky honest that's what he tells
his mom pervy I say is that
five-year-old single gay little forcing
of naked men to be more open with their
sexuality and of course I'm not like a
star
my mom never liked to be he sneezes evil
through his nostrils like squirting milk
from your nose allowing him to transform
and find the boy before turning into a
Decepticon apparently I don't you I'm
just here to be the Deacon Frost pill
and then every David s Goyer script so
the grenades on my last time don't seem
to hurt it they just seem to do this to
him you spend me right round baby right
round like a lady head it is seen that
face no
hey I can see a number of muscle masses
from up here leads do and I'm not going
to lie here a pretty sweet scene where
he transforms a crane into a giant
flaming chainsaw
I can feel my testicle getting bigger
just by watching those no create we must
balance out such mindless violence right
right so after using Satan's weed
whacker Cage gets the boy to safety and
starts to form a father-son bond with
him it's funny because the movie not
only doesn't hide how bad they are at
doing this but they purposely draw
attention to it would be so I was gonna
see your face now I had a bee sting my
face wanted to now look like a bloated
Jon Voight wow it's funny because it's a
jug and you don't usually drink from
jugs you drink from cups is that the
joke there I don't I don't
is this a new level of humor they have
taken comedy and they have just taken it
to a level we just cannot comprehend he
drunk from a jug ha so the devil is over
what's left of it henchmen it brings
them back to life as a Britton matrix
villain
happy hour
the power of decay that's right
everything he touches literally decays
no wait if everything he touches decays
and wide on his clothes decay why do we
the truck he's driving decay why doesn't
every step of grout he's on decay has
the devil given any consideration for
this guy in how he's going to live the
rest of his life so there this is my
dear Minnie I'm so glad we met in that
hot tub it yeah it seems to be the only
place people talk to be looking like
this what do you say we take off all of
our clothes and compare who is whiter I
think that's a good idea baby damn it
happens every time
well guess I can shake the pistol so low
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
something helped ghostwriter is the
devil fallen minion and the boy is
literally the spawn of all evil
obviously they're going to have a lot of
interesting things to discuss and figure
out hey what do we have to pee while
you're alive oh just ask stupid fanboy
questions dude what is your sperm look
like when you're on fire is it as a
family
splooge on fire have you ever
prematurely ejaculated widow fires I
swear that never happens you know I
usually stay in human form but every
once a while you just talk to me a
certain way you think so and you know
that happens I'll bottom lies a phone
over there your local Nile one or
whatever I'm just gonna start scraping
at the door they go to another temple of
mums this time with much less computers
because as you can see they wear their
computers on their faces you mustn't be
afraid it was going to click you hear a
bunch of and halt order my face when I
was drunk this is what I give her
challenging people do more dog guard bed
with AK a cage tells the boy that he's
going to stop being the rider which
pisses the boy off because I don't know
if I picked around on a bike and make
pee jokes it'll be all right I promise
what more oh then shows case the way to
exorcise the spirit Antony's soul the
body of Christ
mmm God hates all better and stay
looking like a true Catholic
Oh God is our dog I am totally working
out on the blood of Christ right now
this is creeping at the door action man
he wakes up on Tatooine to discover that
the months that plans to kill the boy
because certainly that's a Christian
thing to do
no boy is one of God's children now it
is not don't make me play crossword with
your face but everything goes
kaleidoscope vision a saber puss comes
to wipe them all out
why God he picked him to death
he literally mowed him down the jvc me
our heroes escape their confinement
where ever it was and they try to make
their way to save the boy who's going to
be put through the exact same plot as
ghostbusters 2 apparently is riding and
moving in staying with it make more
sense to all özlem and raise them as the
evils of something stupid like this one
happened actually a little time away
from your kids are always a bad idea I
said my little evil lead on a trip to
Texas not too long ago how are you doing
down there sweetie
great I felt discovered how to cause the
pain and suffering of others simply if I
do things my mind listen and that's why
this is the absolute worse Oh God God
again I sure did
Papa's very proud of you they grow up so
fast
so the devil called the whole bunch of
is wealthy followers who all arrived in
black cars of course
well of course how long would we know
they're evil well if you buy the black
robes they're all wearing while chanting
vague Latin
you know I'm not gonna lie I would have
sue Satan the Lord of Darkness would
have a few more followers than that I
mean really
smashmouth has a better turnout than the
unholy demon of life give him some
credit he's been growling and gasping
all of his lines I thought they could
even understand it was him to begin with
is there anyone in this movie who
doesn't look like they're getting higher
some points hey leave the guy could be
going there maybe we can make sense I'm
scraping at the door audio from earlier
Kristin Kristin Kristin
but morale of course being the black guy
has to sacrifice himself meaning the
boys the only one left you can do
anything
boy am i you or you me and I have you or
you have me if you have anything and
this isn't completely done yet why am i
letting you walk up to this guy it just
seems like an ample chance to do that
the boy gives Ghost Rider is powers back
it takes all the evil Souls to hell but
have been fair those people's only crime
was jumping
this of course leads to an exciting
cheese where the devil has to drive a
car over god state why is the devil
driving a fucking car he's the devil
he should be restricted to driving a
fucking car what am I being into stupid
human things he's not a henchman from an
early nineties poverty he's not my day
devil wait a minute in the first one he
lost his powers during the daylight so
why is he able to use them now okay I
don't know what I did there but I'll
take credit for it
I was never afraid to you why would that
make him angry does he have a part-time
job as a haunted house ghost or
something if so I think Nicolas Cage's
Rey your face will be scary enough
well I'm sure I've broken every bone in
that little boy's body this calls for
another job of water hey I want to
ciarán hinds kite ah so we send 20 devil
back to hell give this weird three
amigos balloon and tell the boy that
he's OK ROCK since the rider was an
angel it went crazy
is there ever a moment for Nicolas Cage
not to well I don't know did you mean
I'm going to say yes hell yeah
[Music]
Griffen
till that was ghostwriter spirit of
justice and it okay if I borrow a
certain British phrase please do fucking
bollocks
some things are improvements from the
last one like ghostwriter looked a
little cooler there's some good action
and cage at least has some of his
traditional freak out but it still makes
no sense is annoyingly shot and all the
characters are even more boring cut out
than in the last film there's not enough
screen time with Ghost Rider and even
when he is there he just plays dead
screams and what fun is that anything is
a constant pain in the arse
most of the jokes fall flat and it's
just all around or fall no to be here
well they so much DVD recording of Mike
J anytime always happy to predict your
mediocrity British twat oh by the way
look out for the ghost pony rider cameo
look good pony rider I knew we'd get in
there somehow Islander Sacha Critic I
remember it so you don't have
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's watch it some go
straighter to that cage
I think huh was he always British yeah
not a lot of people know that well if he
doesn't flow up something soon I'm just
going to start reading by Jane Austen
devil baby mama